[موسيقى]
اعتاد بعض الذين يخالفون التوجه الاغلبيه
للناس الذي يتسم عاده بالبساطه وباتباع
الفطره السليمه على وصف خيار الاكثريه
بانه يشبه السير مع القطيع قطيع الماعز
فهل هم بوصفهم هذا يصفون انفسهم دون قصد
منهم بان منهجهم الشوفينيه المستعلي على
بني جلدتهم يشبه سلوكا نخبه التيوس
الشارده الى العناوين
انتخابات رئاسه تركيا تنتقل الى التصفيه
النهائيه بين اردوغانو
الاضعف في الدوره الاولى هل يملك الركله
الترجيحيه في الدوره الثانيه
ستون نائبا جمهوريا يطالبون بفحص القدرات
العقليه لجو بايدن قبل الانتخابات
قمه في نيويورك جمعت بين الرئيس محمود
عباس ونجم الفن الهابط محمد رمضان
قضاء قيس سعيد على المعارضه يسجن راشد
الغنوشي سنه كامله
شباب المغرب والجزائر
يتعانقون عناق اخوه برغم خلافات الحكومتين
شبحوا جنيه في شقه مهجوره بالجزائر يثير
الرعب ويهجر سكان البنايه
اسامه الازهري يفتخر بتبرك البسطاء بحذائه
ورفعه على الاعناق في اندونيسيا
قيس الخزعلي يحمل المساده الاسرائيلي
مسؤوليه اغتيال الامام علي
[موسيقى]
مرحبا انتهت انتخابات القرن التركي
بمتقدم غير رابح ومتاخر غير خاسر وبعود
على بدء فقد اطلقت صفاره الانتقال الى
الصوت الثاني بفارق اسبوعين سيشكلان ملحقا
لحملات انتخابيه صاخبه
وفي الصوت الثاني لاعب احتياط قومي متشدد
سيسدد ركلته الترجيحيه لصالح من يتعهد له
بنبذ الجماعات الكرديه التي يعتبرها
ارهابيه وبطرد اللاجئين من البلاد بكل
الاحوال في الاعاده افاده لكلا المتنافسين
فحتى الرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان يحتاج الى
تحسين رقم فوزه الرئاسيا في موازاه تصدر
تحالفه نتائج انتخابات البرلمان كي لا
يعود الى القصر ضعيفا
اما كمال كليتش دارغلو فستنقذه الجوله
الثانيه من الانتخابات ان استطاع تجميع
الفراطات الانتخابيه لصالحه قبل ان تتفرفط
كتلته الصلبه من حوله باستقالات واقالات
كان ابرزها استقاله نائب كليتش دار من حزب
الشعب الجمهوري امريكا واوروبا
عولتا على كليتش دار وعلى حشده الشعبي
لاسقاط اردوغان بالضربه الانتخابيه
القاضيه بحسب وزير الداخليه التركيه
سليمان سويلو لكن الانتخابات في تركيا لا
تتسموا بميزه سرعه الجملوكيات العربيه حيث
نستطيع معرفه نتائج انتخاباتنا قبل ان
تبدا
وبسنوات اذا طالت اعمارهم طالت اعمارهم
لكن تركيا حتى الان يصنع شعبها سلطته
بورقه الاقتراع كي لا تكون تركيا ورقه بيد
الشرق والغرب فيما نصنع نحن سلطتنا وفوق
السلطه رشه خل حامض يقول خليل رفيقه لبهيج
تستعد تركيا لجوله اعاده في سابقه في
تاريخ الجمهوريه التركيه
فاردوغان الذي تقدم على منافسه كيليتش دار
اوغلو اخفق بفارق طفيف عن تحقيق النسبه
المطلوبه مؤيده يقولون انه واثقون من فوزه
في الجوله الثانيه انا متاكده من ان
اردوغان سيفوز اعتقد انه سيحصل على اصوات
سنانو غان في المعسكر المقابل ورغم القلق
ما زال انصار كلتش دار اولو ياملون بفوز
مرشحهم اعتقد انه يمكننا الفوز في الجوله
الثانيه لكنني خائفه حقا مما يمكن ان يحصل
في الاسبوعين المقبلين
المرشح القومي المتشدد هو صاحب الخمسه
بالمئه من الاصوات التي حولته بحسب
تحليلات ربما تكونوا فضفاضه جدا حولته الى
قابض على مفاتيح القصر الجمهوري التركي
هذا ان كان يملك فعلا القدره على تجير
اصوات من انتخبوه في الدوره الاولى بكل
الاحوال هو حدد شروطه لدعم هذا المرشح او
ذاك ابرزها محاربه الارهاب ويقصد بذلك
التخلي عن التعاون مع الاحزاب الكرديه
الانفصاليه برايه ثانيا اعاده اللاجئين
السوريين وغيرهم الى بلادهم فورا وقصرا
اذا لزم الامر المفارقه المضحكه هي ان
سنان افندي مهاجر مهاجر الى تركيا في
الاصل حيث تمتد جذ عائلته الى اذربيجان
كذلك قائد التحالف الاجداد الذي رشحه
للرئاسه رئيس حزب الظفر اليمني السوبر
متشددال هو من اصول داغستانيه ولد في
اليابان ودرس في المانيا ثم عاد الى تركيا
ليطوفه يوميا في شوارعها منقبا عن
السوريين
لتوعدهم بالطرد لكن الاتراك طردوه هذه
المره من البرلمان حيث عجز عن الاحتفاظ
بمقعده النيابي في النهايه يخطب المرشحان
الرئاسيان الان كريس داروغلو واردوغان ود
ناخبيه سنان اوغان سنانوجان المرشح
الرئاسي المستقل الذي تحول الى صانع ملوك
بحصوله على 5% من الاصوات سيكون محور
الاهتمام في الايام المقبله اردوغان ينطبق
عليه الشرط الاول هو الخصم الرئيسي لحزب
الشعوب الكردي اما في موضوع اللاجئين فهو
تحدث عن عوده طوعيه بدات في صفوفهم الى
سوريا لكنه يرفض طردهم لاعتبارات اسلاميه
وانسانيه كما قال وقال اردوغان تركيا دوله
99% من سكانها مسلمون وهناك شعب سوري اضطر
الى مغادره بلاده بسبب الحرب والتنظيمات
الارهابيه فهل يعقل ان نطردهم هذا تصرف
غير انساني ولا اخلاقي والاهم من ذلك ليس
اسلاميا ماذا عن
هل يتخلى عن سله الاصوات الحزبيه الكرديه
التي تقارب ضعف حموله سنان اوغان بكامل
طاقتها
وقف باعوامه الخمسه والسبعين لطم على صدره
خبط على طاولته وهتف قائلا انا هنا والله
سينا نوجان سبق ان انتقد ترشح كليتش
داروغلو وهو في عقده الثامن فدافع عنه
المذيع مستشهدا بسن الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن ليعلق سينان و يصافح الهواء الان هل
تريد ان يحكمن شخص مثله وقع هذا الاسبوع
اكثر من 60 نائبا جمهوريا امريكيا على
رساله الى الرئيس بايدن يطالبونه فيها
باجراء اختبار لقدراته العقليه قبل الترشح
رسميا الى السباق الرئاسي
تائه في غابه النجوم عنوان الفيديو الجديد
لشبكه روسيا اليوم الرسمي عن بايدن في
نيويورك
[موسيقى]
بايدن لم يكن تائها ابدا في تقييم الموقف
الجديد في تركيا بعد ان جرت الرياح بعكس
التوقعات الغربيه
ليفز في تركيا من يفوز قال
قبل ذلك كان الموقف مختلفا تماما كان
ليبوز في تركيا اي شخص الا اردوغان
في عنوان
[موسيقى]
كما في كل مره بعد العدوان الاسرائيلي على
غزه واتفاق وقف اطلاق النار يبدا مسح
الاضرار كل ذكرياته راحت مع تدبير بيته في
القطاع
[موسيقى]
في المقابل احتفت حركه الجهاد الاسلامي
وفصائل المقاومه الفلسطينيه بالانتصار بعد
وقف اطلاق النار وشكل المتحدث باسم الجهاد
محور المقاومه لكنه اسقط سهوا ربما من
المحور الحشد الشعبي العراقي الذي يصفه
محاسبوه بالمقدس
تحيتنا وشكرنا وعرفاننا لمحور المقاومه
وعلى راسه سوريا العروبه ولبنان المقاومه
بحزب الله الابي واليمن الشجاع وكذلك
التحيه للجمهوريه الاسلاميه في ايران
وللحرس الثوري وقوه القدس الذين كانوا
معنا خطوه بخطوه فيثار الاحرار نهايه جوله
العدوان الاسرائيلي على غزه تزامنت مع
ذكرى نكبه فلسطين باحتلالها لمن فاتته
المعلومات من الجيل الجديد عن النكبه هذه
عينه منها بحسب معلقين رئيس منظمه تحرير
فلسطين محمود عباس يحقق حلمه اخيرا بلقاء
محمد رمضان نجم الفن الهابط بلا منازع
واخيرا التقيناك يا صاحب الفن العظيم
كمان احنا بنسمع عنك كل الاخبار الطيبه
الله يخليك والفن العظيم
لقاء القمه الذي جمع محمود ومحمد مع حفظ
الالقاب جرى في نيويورك على هامش القاء
الرئيس عباس كلمه في الامم المتحده
بمناسبه ذكرى النكبه مذكرا الدول العظمى
بانها تحمل الحيوانات مضيفا احمونا السنا
بشرا
ينال في عالم سمونه حمونه
مش بني ادمين مش بشر حتى حيوانات لازم
نحميها ولا لا
لو كان عندك حيوان ما بتحميه
صوره العمليه تتمثل حسب وزاره الداخليه في
اقدام احد عواني الحرس الوطني للمركز
البحري باغير جربه على قتل زميله بسلاحه
الفردي والاستيلاء على الذخيره ثم محاولته
التوجه الى محيط معبد الغريبه والبدء في
اطلاق النار بشكل عشوائي على عناصر قوات
الامن المتمركز بالمكان التي تصدت له
ومنعته من الوصول الى المعبد واردته قتيلا
الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد يبتعد عن وصف
هجوم جربه بالارهابي فهو يريد منطقيا ان
ينتظر التحقيقات كي لا يقع في نفس اخطائه
شبه اليوميه عندما يصف معارضيه بانهم
ارهابيون بدون قصاصه ورقه من اي تحقيق
ومثل هذه العمليات الاجراميه عرفتها
الكثير من الدول ولا تزال تعاني منه
اختاره هؤلاء المجرمون معبد الغريب نح
الارهابيه لعده مرات تعاود كلمه اجره
مجرمون هذا جرم صبغه ارهابيه شنو هو
التعريف الارهاب ارهب الناس هو حب يرهب
الناس لكنه هو امتص منها الصبغه
عن الرئيس قيس سعيد استسهاله قذف خصومه
المسالمين ووصف كل مخالفيه
بالارهابيين هؤلاء الذين تم اعتقالهم
ارهابيين لان الرئيس البرلماني المنحل
ورئيس حركه النهضه راشد الغنوشي استخدم في
السابق مصطلح طواغيت وجد قضاءه حاكم تونس
حجه لتبرير سجده سنه كامله لا احد يعلم ان
كان الغنوشي قادرا على اكمالها في ظل
ظروفه الصحيه والعمريه قبل اكثر من سنه
هذه الشكايه تعود الى انا الرئيس حركه
النهضه استعمل في احد
تصريحاته خلال تقديم احد قيادات حركه
النهضه نفض الطاغوت واعتبر ان هذا اللفظ
هو بمثابه بمثابه المس من قوات الامن صدر
ضد او هذا الحكم اي بسنه سجنا وخطيره
ماليه قدرها نحو الف دينار هل يعلم رئيس
تونس ان المسنين في بلاده يبحثون الان عن
طريق للهجره غير النظاميه من الوطن وباي
ثمن من اكثر الحاجات اللي اثارت الاستغراب
انه اليوم المتقاعدين والمسنين اليوم هما
زادها واليوم الفئات العمريه المعنيه
بعمليه الحرقل هل اجتهد الرئيس تونس في
الوقوف عند الخبر المروع باحراق رجل
ستيديا زوجته وابنته هل بحث عن اسباب
الجريمه الاجتماعيه العنوان يقول سكب
البنزين على زوجته وابنته واحرقهما جريمه
تهز تونس توفيت الضحيه لتبلغ من العمر 60
عام
متاثره بالحروق اللي لحقت بها في جسدها
رغم محاوله اسعافها بينما لا تزال الابنه
تخضع للعلاج داخل المستشفى في حين تم
اعتقال الزوج بعد تسليم نفسه للسلطات
الامنيه واعترافه بارتكاب الجريمه هل يعلم
حاكم تونس ان سائقي شاحنات نقل الخضار
باتوا في عهده يخافون ان تتعطل شاحناتهم
كي لا تتعرض حمولتها للسرقه تاجر جمله
يتعرض لحادث خطير على تاريخ كيندار تنقلب
بالشاحنه فيهرع الناس مش لمساعده الذئاب
الاستيلاء على حقك على حقوق
كميون الجازوس
يذبوا عليه ليشرب يشرب واللي يحب يبيع
عقليه
بالفقر الناس يمكن جيعانه غادي الناس في
كروش جيعانه ماهيش لقيامه
لوحه جديده تعكس عمق الاخوه بين الشعبين
الجزائري والمغربي رغم التوتر بين
الحكومتين سوره العامل المغاربيه التقطت
في ملعب الشهيد حملاوي بقسنطينه شرق
الجزائر ويظهر بوضوح وقوف اللاعبين من
المنتخب المغربي مع اللاعبين من المنتخب
الجزائري متابطين بعضهم البعض ومتجاوزين
الخلافات بين ساسه بلديهما
وتنافسا بروح رياضيه عاليه في الدوري
الجزائري مشجع رياضي صغير لم تشغله لعبه
الكبار ومعشوقه الصغار عن صلاته التي
اقامها في ركن جانبي من المدرجات
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
هي حياتي دنيتي
[موسيقى]
التفسيرات تعددت وبرز فيها اتهام بسعي
احدهم لتهجير المستاجرين ما يفيدنا من هذه
القصه ان جنيه متخيله هجرت بصراخها سكان
بدايه تعاطف معهم كل الناس في امكنه اخرى
اجتمعت شياطين الارض على شعوب مستضعفه
فهجرها صراخ مقاتلات لا ترحم من السخوي
الى الرفال الى بنات اعمامهن الاف سته عشر
والثاني وعشرين وخمسه وثلاثين ارتكبت
مجازر اباده فلجا الناجون الى القريب
والبعيد لكنهم تحولوا لاحقا الى بند
للمزايدات للانتخابيه بطردهم الذي ربما
يشكل حمله اباده جديده
[موسيقى]
يقول رسول الله محمد صلى الله عليه وسلم
من احب ان يمثل له الرجال قياما فليتبوا
مقعده من النار هذا عن السجناء وقوف
الرجال فكيف بمن احب ان يحمل على اعناق
الرجال اسامه الازهري شيخ ازهري ومستشار
رئاسي مصري لكنه اذا غادر الحي الذي يسكن
فيه ما في حدا بيعرفه من العوام ذهب الى
اندونيسيا فاستقبله شعبها المسلم الذي
يقدر الرمزيه العلميه للعمامه الازهريه
فتحمس بعض الشباب وحملوه فوق اعناقهم على
هودج تجاوب معهم الشيخ بخفه غير معهوده في
اوساط العلماء ومد قدميه ليتبرك بعض
الجهال بحذائه
سوما الازهري عاد الى الفندق لينشر صوره
وصور حذائه فوق الاعناق على وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي بص حضرتك هنا الراجل اهو مبسوط
قوي وعمال يخبط على صدره سعيد وهنا
الجماعه الطيبين دول شايفين راجل ازهري
جايلهم فعنده يعني قدسيه جميله فبدا ايه
يطلع لهم الجزمه بتاعته اهو زي ما انتم
شايفين كده على الشمال
والناس بتمسح على الجزمه
واسامه الازهري مبسوط قوي قوي قوي لاحقا
علق اسامه الازهري معتبرا حمله بهذه
الطريقه تكريما لمصر والازهر وليس لشخصه
فهل يقبل او هل يجرؤ اسامه ان يحمل على
الاعناق في مصر
الامام الطيب محمد متولي الشعراوي رحمه
الله لماذا يدوم ذكره الى الان فيما تمضي
قوافل التجار بدون اي اثر علامه عصره
الشعراوي نظف المراحيض كي لا يتبوا مقعده
من النار الشباب اللي كانوا موجودين جوه
المحاضره اتلموا حوالين عربيه الشيخ محمد
متولي الشعراوي ومن حبهم في فضيله الشيخ
محمد متولي الشعراوي كان عايزين يرفعوا
العربيه من على الارض وهو جواها طبعا
الشيخ محمد متولي الشعراوي اتضايق من
المشهد ومن اللي بيحصل المهم السواق مشي
بالعربيه وهم في الطريق كانوا معديين قدام
مسجد فضيله الشيخ قال لي السواق اقف قدام
المسجد ده لقى فضيله الشيخ محمد متولي
الشعراوي بيمسح حمامات المسجد ابن اندهش
ابويا الشيخ محمد متولي الشعراوي يمسح
حمامات المسجد وساله انت ليه بتعمل كده
بتمسح حمامات المسجد رد عليه فضيله الشيخ
انا لما الشباب كانوا بيرفعوا العربيه من
على الارض وانا جواها حسيت ان نفسي هتبقى
مغروره جيت هنا واتعمدت اني امسح حمامات
المسجد عشان اكسرها واذلها
توصل زعيم العصائب الشيخ قيس الخزعلي الى
تحديد الجهه التي تقف خلف عمليه اغتيال
الامام علي كرم الله وجهه الموساد
الاسرائيلي لقد فعلها الموساد قبل الف
واربع مئه عام هذه قطعا ويقينا كانت تعمل
لجهاز الموساد الاسرائيلي في ذات الوقت
ومن خلالها
جندوا عبد الشيطان ابن مجرم حاشا لله ان
يكون اختيار علي بن ابي طالب بسبب شنو سبب
قضايا جنائيه وقضايا شخصيه
ختاما كان زعيم عصابه يكره اظهار حجم
ثروته فاختار حارسا على الخزنه اصم ابكم
لكنه اكتشف بعد سنين ان الحارس اختلس عشره
ملايين دولار اراد الزعيم استرجاعها فاحضر
خبيرا بلغه الاشاره واجتمع الثلاثه ووضع
الزعيم مسدسه في راس الحارس نقل المترجم
التهديد بلغه الاشاره فكاد الحارس يفقد
وعيه واعترف سريعا بفعلته وقال النقود في
حقيبه سوداء مدفونه خلف المستودع ماذا قال
لك سال الزعيم فاجابه المترجم قال انك
كذاب وجبال تستقوى عليه لانه ضعيف
كلمات مقتضبات كاذبات كانت كافيه ليقتل
زعيم العصابه الحارس بالرصاص ويخسر عشره
ملايين دولار
ذهبت بلغه الاشاره الى اللقاء
دنيا
رزق
والباقي خير
[موسيقى]